you were on i mean one of your early
roles was you got to play
steve carell's nephew on an episode of
the office is that that's right actually
more than one episode wasn't it no just
one just once
um what was that a great experience he's
such a you know fantastic
actor great guy yeah he's so funny and
so nice and uh
oddly enough it was it was the scene
where uh i was leaned over his desk
getting kidding you have been typecast
wait you really were i think this is
true you really were spanked in that
scene i was yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah right yeah i wish on your card it
just
was like now we're going to spank you
yeah just everywhere you go people can't
help but like yeah it's part of the
time yeah yeah you inspire it yeah did
he fake spanky or do you really go for
it no he went for it he
he basically said he you know kind of
leaned into me as i was leaned over his
desk and said
hey man i'm i'm really going to go for
it
all right what a strange thing i swear i
said all right get in there what an
odd strange thing to say in that
situation welcome to hollywood
yeah it's how we got our job
yeah go to town buddy whatever it takes
yeah as long as we get the check
what's about the x-men franchise we
talked about this i talked to you about
it once
your quicksilver scene where you're
running in the kitchen is one of my
favorite scenes
in a science fiction movie of all time i
think that's a brilliant scene
i loved it we're obviously we can't show
it because it would cost me
i think six hundred thousand dollars to
show it wow andy offered to pony it up
and i said no no but um
such a great scene such a great
character do you know if you're going to
be
coming back for more i don't know knock
on wood i hope so i mean i would love to
come back i mean it's a dream come true
playing
playing quicksilver and being in the
x-men film so i would i would absolutely
love to come back i hope you do yeah
i would hope that would happen because i
just i think every one of them has been
brilliant and i love watching with my
kids
thanks man it's the only time i really
hang with my kids okay
they will only hang with me if there's
an x-men film involved wow
yeah it's really sad more than funny
yeah well anyway
what's wrong with you people